you
have you ever been floating in a
swimming pool all comfy and warm
thinking man it'd be cool to be an
astronaut you could float out in outer
space look down at the earth and
everything would be so neat only that's
not how it is at all if you are in outer
space you are orbiting the Earth
it's called freefall you're actually
falling towards the earth all right
think about this for a moment that's the
feeling you get if you're going over the
top of a roller coaster going like whoa
only you're doing this the whole time
you're orbiting the Earth for two three
four hours days whatever it takes right
so how does orbiting work let's take a
page from Isaac Newton he had this idea
a little mental experiment you take a
cannon you put it on top of a hill if
you shoot the Cannonball it goes a
little bit ways but if you shoot it
harder it goes far enough so that it
lands a little bit past the curvature of
the earth well you can imagine if he
shot it really really really hard it
would go all the way around the earth
and come back boom and like hit them in
the backside or something all right
let's zoom way back it put you in a
little satellite over the North Pole
here and consider North to be up you're
gonna fall down and hit the earth but
you are actually moving sideways really
fast so when you fall down you're gonna
miss you're gonna end up on the side of
the earth falling down and now the earth
is pulling you back in sideways all
right and so it's pulling you back in
and you fall down and so you miss the
earth again and now you're under the
earth and the earth is going to pull you
up but you're moving sideways still so
you're gonna miss the earth again and
now you're on the other side of the
earth moving upward and the Earth's
pulling you sideways all right so you
are gonna fall sideways but you're gonna
be moving up into a Miss and now you're
back on top of the earth again over the
North Pole going sideways and falling
down and yep you guessed it you'll keep
missing because you're moving so fast in
this way astronauts orbit the earth
they're always falling towards the Earth
but they're always missing and therefore
they're falling all the time they feel
like they're falling so you just have to
kind of get over it so technically if
you ran fast enough and tripped you
could miss the earth but there's a big
problem first you have to be going eight
kilometers a second that's 18,000 miles
an hour just over Mach 20
the second problem if you're going that
fast yes you would orbit the Earth and
come back where you came from but
there's a lot of air in the way all
right much less people in things so you
would burn up due to atmospheric
friction so I do not recommend this
you